- Eh oui!
- Ce sont les Australiennes
qui l'emportent devant
les États-Unis...
- Magnifique!
- Et nos Canadiennes sont
médaillées de bronze!
- Et une septième médaille
olympique pour Penny Oleksiak!
On voit l'histoire olympique
s'écrire devant nous
pour le Canada.
- Elle a à peine 21 ans
et la voici reine du sport
olympique canadien.
- Ouiiii! Première!
- Penny Oleksiak a décroché
une médaille d'or, deux
médailles d'argent et quatre
de bronze en seulement
deux Olympiades.
(hymne national canadien)
La Torontoise devance
maintenant Clara Hughes
et Cindy Klaussen qui ont
remporté six médailles chacune.
À la sortie de la piscine,
Penny Oleksiak rayonnait.
Modeste, elle était heureuse
de pouvoir partager son exploit
avec ses coéquipières.
Ce qui est encore plus
exceptionnel, c'est son retour
au sommet à Tokyo après
les années difficiles qui ont
suivi les Jeux de Rio.
Aucune médaille en épreuves
individuelles lors des grands
rendez-vous internationaux.
Les succès grandioses de Penny
Oleksiak vont rejaillir sur la
natation canadienne et inspirer
une nouvelle génération.
BENOIT HUOT,
analyste de natation
- C'est fantastique pour
l'avenir du sport. Ça inspire
bien sûr les jeunes et moins
jeunes à s'impliquer, mais
particulièrement la relève.
Il va certainement y avoir
des Penny Oleksiak qui vont
se développer au fil des années
qui vont, espérons-le, être sur
des podiums dans des décennies.
- Les nageuses canadiennes ont
déjà pris goût à la victoire.
Elles ont récolté six médailles
à Tokyo.
En cette journée historique
pour le sport canadien,
la jeune équipe exceptionnelle
de nageuses promet d'être encore
mieux préparée, plus forte
en 2024, à peine dans 3 ans,
à Paris. Ça promet.
Ici Philippe Leblanc,
Radio-Canada, T